hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well in
lecture 31 the dissection of the
psychical personality sigmund freud
is going to tell us how the
super ego is related to and
emerges out of what he calls parental
authority
the parental function parental agency
there's a lot of different names for it
but it
it's talking about actually existing
people in the relation to the
child so these could be parents in the
traditional sense mother and father
biological parents they could also be
adoptive parents we could talk about
caretakers
of many other sorts as well which could
include
other family members could be people
within an orphanage
the point is is that a child
originally does not have a super ego
this is something that develops
out of the child's
engagements with relations with
reactions to
what is happening in relation to them
on the part of these adults
and you know these adults don't
necessarily have to be all that old they
could be
16 year old kids who are you know having
a baby
and raising a toddler it could be
you know any sort of myriad
configurations that we're talking about
here
they don't have to be good parents they
don't have to be particularly well
informed but there is something that we
can call
a parental function that the
superego is going to emerge out of
and freud tells us that prior to the
development
of the superego what we really have
is you know something like an amoral
child he says young children are amoral
and possess
no internal inhibitions against their
impulses striving for
pleasure they they want to do things
right what keeps them from doing the
things
that they shouldn't do or that adults
don't want them to do the adult
intervening
in some way i've sometimes joked that
when you have a two-year-old because you
know i had children myself
your main job from two to four years old
is to keep them from killing themselves
as they go around and
explore the world so you're giving a lot
of prohibitions
but you're also giving a lot of other
guidance
and so freud tells us the part which is
later taken on by the superego when it's
internalized
within the child and then the adult is
played to begin with by
an external power something outside
of the child by parental authority
and he tells us how this works parental
influence
governs the child by offering proofs of
love and
threatening punishments which are signs
to the child of loss of love and are
bound to be feared
on their own account so what we have
here is reward
and punishment as you know very basic
ways levers you might say of modifying
behavior and attitudes and these can
take
on you know literally thousands of
shapes even the same action might be
viewed in one context as a sign of love
and in another context is a sign of
displeasure think about the smile
for example smiling at somebody in one
way it could be
showing benevolence love you know
affection
smiling at them in another way might be
showing that you're
ticked off with them and they better not
do that one more time or they're getting
punished in some way or
pick any other thing that you want an
abusive person might be smiling because
they're
thinking oh i've got this this child in
my power
now so the child is engaging with
the the adults and they as he says
experience
realistic anxiety which is the precursor
of later
moral anxiety and and freud goes on to
say so long as
it meaning the parental authority is
dominant there's no need to talk of a
super ego
and a conscience a superego a conscience
that's something that you have within
yourself and as freud is saying look
children don't have that to start with
that is something that is
you might say an achievement it is
something that
develops in healthy normal development
within a person now the superego makes a
lot of trouble for us in many ways but
we actually
do do needed freud things for proper
human development so we've got parental
authority and influence you know
rewarding and punishing at the start and
then
something new happens so he goes on and
he says
it's only subsequently that the
secondary
situation develops now this is a very
important
point secondary meaning that there is no
innate conscience in human beings as
they're born
as they develop it's something that
develops
and it develops through the contingent
relationships with the external world
which includes
other people and then can begin
you know producing this splitting within
the ego that the super ego
is going to come out of it and attain
its own sort of agency
so he tells us it's it's uh subsequently
that the secondary situation develops
which were all red to ready to regard as
the normal one
where the external restraint coming from
the parent or figure is internalized
and the superego takes the place of the
parental agency and observes directs and
threatens the
ego in exactly the same way as the
parents did
with the child so this is this is quite
important
and there's a number of different
features and
dynamics that freud is going to lay out
here
in relation to the parent of the child
the first thing that he says is that the
superego takes over the power
functions and methods of parental agency
so this is a very important point the
parent at a certain point doesn't have
to tell the child what to do
because they have internalized it i'll
give you a prime example
of when i was a kid and where
a superego was perhaps a little bit too
developed and the superego was perhaps
not developed enough
my mother you know after my father died
would in the summer leave lists of
chores for
myself and for my sister
and these are things that we were
supposed to do during the day usually
there'd be like about eight chores and
some of them would be easy things to do
some of them might take a whole hour and
some of them would be you know
fun some of them would be unpleasant and
so
i you know i knew i needed to get my
chores in now i was also older than my
sister
as well and so i would like knock out
the stuff that i really didn't want to
do right away i'm following the dictates
of the super ego right
you know and then i get to play and and
i i
get that reward my sister would
wait until the last hour of the day
before my mom was going to get home
put her around doing whatever she wanted
for the first part of the day
and then go and try to
knock out all the chores at once and it
usually wouldn't work and then she would
get in trouble
you know so this would be an example of
like a super ego not being as quite as
developed you know the superego allows
us to be
guided it also is not you know
a nice faculty to have
but he tells us so the superego is not
merely the successor to parental agency
but the legitimate heir of its body and
he tells us it proceeds out of it
um but you know before we go into that
he says we have to
we have to look at a discrepancy between
the two now this is
very interesting so he tells us that the
superego
is selective it doesn't totally
internalize the parent
as a matter of fact there might be an
internalization of other parts of the
parent that the superego leaves out
the superego picks up on the strictness
the severity perhaps even the cruelty
of the the parent the demands that
things be met
says they're prohibiting and punitive
function what doesn't get brought in
their loving care
or affection or anything like that and
freud says
you know this would actually make a lot
of sense
if we had parents who are you know
overly strict
you've got a parent who's mean to you
and
you know very demanding well then you're
going to have this internalized
parent who becomes the super ego
but does this make sense in terms of
parents who are actually
nice to you and freud says in my
experience and now he's saying this
after
having seen quite a few patients he says
experience shows that the superego can
acquire the same characteristic of
relentless severity even if the
upbringing had been mild
and kindly and it's so far as possible
avoided threats and punishments
so he sees this as a sort of
contradiction and he'll talk about this
in other places
the super ego is not exactly the same
thing as the internalized parent we can
see from
this because it doesn't have the
love the affection of the parent instead
it has the judginess
the criticizing the whatever else we
want to call it
making us fearful now he also has a long
distance discussion here about
identification
and he tells us towards the end of it
that
the installation of the superego can be
described as a successful
instance of identification with the
parental
agency now what does all that mean so if
we go back a little bit earlier he says
the basis of this process is
what is called an identification the
assimilation
of one ego to another one assimilation
means becoming
like becoming similar to so you
resemble your parents whether you like
it or not i mean
when we're adolescents we're often like
oh i'm never going to be like mom and
dad right but
as it turns out we often are when we
have our own kids
we get to see this even more so but we
we eventually
we take on a lot of their own traits
and so he says the you know as a result
of which the first ego
behaves like the second in certain
respects imitates it and in a sense
takes it into itself so there's there's
a
double meaning to this assimilation
right there's assimilating in the sense
of like
making myself similar to them but it's
also like taking them
into me and making them a part of me
so he goes on and he says um
it's a very important form of attachment
to somebody else probably the first
and not the same thing as the choice of
an object an
object of desire right an object of of
whatever else it's going to be says the
difference can be expressed in some way
such as this if a boy identifies himself
with his father
he wants to be like his father if he
makes him the object of his choice he
wants to have him
to possess him in the first case his ego
is altered on the
model of his father in the second case
that is not
necessary and so you know he speculates
a little bit about how
different these these can be and he
tells us that you know this can also
happen with lost
objects we don't need to worry too much
about about that
but what's going on here well that's
preparing the way
for assimilating not just the ego of the
other but also
as he's going to say a little bit later
they're super ego
so what is what is actually being
likened what is actually being made the
same here
i might in fact be adopting
my own dad's ego which is being harassed
by his
own super ego or things like that
he also brings in the oedipus complex
now this is something that is pretty
controversial
freud may have made way too much of this
but i
don't think that in order to use the
idea of the superego we necessarily have
to
be literalists about the oedipus complex
but we should say a little bit
what it means so in the oedipus complex
and there's also theorized something you
know that would be correlative to it
in the electorate complex the the child
uh the male child wants to like oedipus
kill his father
marry his mother although this is you
know not in a very literal sense they
wants to
retain the affection of the
the mother it feels the father to be a
rival
wants to displace him somehow realizes
that the father is
stronger more powerful more powerful
more capable
begins to identify with the father
begins to to assimilate the father
and now notice that that freud in
talking about it here
he doesn't say that that's all we're
doing our whole life
the oedipus complex for freud is not
something
that characterizes adult humans unless
they're really screwed up
unless they never made it through to the
end of the oedipus complex instead
the superego emerges out of
the oedipus complex and as he says is
going to
in some respect replace it so he tells
us
there's a new creation of the superior
agency within the ego
it's most intimately linked with the
destiny of the oedipus complex how so
so that the superego appear appears as
the heir
of that emotional attachment which is of
such importance for childhood
with the abandonment of the oedipus
complex a child
must as we can see renounce the intense
object cathexes which he's deposited
with his parents
and it is as a compensation for this
loss of
objects that there is such a strong
identification
intensification of the identifications
with his parents
which has probably been long present in
his ego
so he goes on and he says it's when the
oedipus complex
hasn't actually been resolved that you
get a screwed up
super ego he says the superego is
stunted in its strength and growth if
the surmounting of the
oedipus complex is only incompletely
successful so this is a very important
point you don't actually need the
oedipus complex
as a matter of fact you're going to
leave it behind so you've got the super
ego
right he also talks about
later parents now this is kind of an
interesting
phrase to use it's got a double meaning
who are we talking about well freud
tells us that the superego
is formed not just through the agency of
the parents
but also as he says um
[Music]
here we go the influences of those
who've stepped into the place
of parents who are they educators
teachers people chosen as ideal
models and that could be sports figures
that could be
musicians that could be celebrities of
different sorts right
they function as alternative
or later parents he says normally it
departs more and more from the original
parental figures it becomes so to say
more impersonal and then he also talks
about like
as you get older you and this is what
happens in
adolescence right you come to realize
that your parents are not
as infallible or
as good or as persevering
or as consistent as you'd like they kind
of come down from their pedestal
this probably happens earlier for some
than for others
and as a result they have less you know
these are the later parents
and he says identifications come about
with these later parents
and indeed they regularly make important
contributions to the formation of
character but they only affect the ego
the superego has been formed by that
time
so your super ego is not the mom and dad
who you come to know as a 20 year old
and you can relate to their problems and
midlife crises
and you know you feel a little empathy
for them it's the
person you knew at five years old who
was younger and probably dumber than
they
are at 40 and when you're 20 right or
whatever the age difference is going to
be
so this is this is a very important
point the last thing that we want to
bring up
is that as freud says
you're not often dealing directly
with the parents egos in
how they've formed you becoming part of
your super ego
you're actually inheriting
or being affected by their own super
egos that are making
them miserable as well so he says
uh here we go as a rule
parents and authorities analogous to
them follow the precepts of their own
super egos
in educating children whatever
understanding their ego may have come to
with their super ego they are severe and
exacting and educating children
they've forgotten the difficulties of
their own childhood and they're glad to
not
to be able now to identify themselves
fully with their own parents
who in the past laid these restrictions
on them so he says thus
a child super ego is in fact constructed
on the model
not of its parents but of its parents
super ego
the contents which fill it are the same
and it becomes a vehicle of tradition
leading to tradition
ideology and now if we go back to
freud's point
about the super ego takes on this this
severity
even when parents are not themselves
severe but are loving they're kind
they're nice they're benevolent
that means that even if you're reacting
against your parents
i'm not going to be a mean jerk like
them
you're also still from a freudian
perspective you're going to give rise
to a you know a child super ego that
somehow still becomes
demanding and severe with them
now you know how how much of this is
empirically
borne out how much of this is a matter
of of
cultural assumptions those are questions
that we don't have to
go into too much but not at this point
this is how freud pictures the super ego
emerging out of
and supplanting within the
child and then later adult who carries
around with them
uh the superego related to their ego
parental authority gives way to this
faculty or
agency of the superego
you